One of my college professors really liked to say that DNA,
and life in general, is really just organic chemistry that crawls.
>> I like that analogy, but once we start talking about
chemistry is DNA, it's just a little out of my league Matt.
>> Yeah, it's true. The, the details in chemistry can
be a little complex, especially if you don't have the chemistry
background. and really those details are out of the scope of
our course, so what we're going to do is replace the chemistry
with symbols, or our letters, to make things easier.
>> I mean, I like it. It does seem a little easier. And just looking at the
letters, I think I can see a pattern. Oh,
what kind of pattern do you think you see?
>> Well, if I look at one side I think I
can judge the letters that are going to be in the other, right?
>> Yeah, that's actually really good and important. Sometimes
when we discover a new genome, and we don't
know much about it yet, we want to know
what it's made of. Being able to count the number
of Adenines, Thymines, Guanines, Cytosines, the As,
Ts, Gs and Cs, the letters of
DNA, can actually give us information. About
how many genes might be in that genome.
>> So take a look at this strand here. Now, if I don't
give you the other side can you tell me what percentage of the
whole DNA structure is guanines or Gs? Now this can get a little
tricky so if you get stuck take a look at the base pairing rules.